[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit gundula
gause und bettina schausten guten abend
das war zu befürchten
bundesfinanzminister lindner hat sich
mit seinem antrag bei der gas umlage
keine mehrwertsteuer zu erheben ein
blaues auge geholt absage aus brüssel es
könne keine ausnahme geben lindner ging
es wohl ohnehin vor allem um das signal
des guten willens der regierung die
menschen nicht über gebühr zu belasten
brüssel und berlin wollen nun nach
anderen lösungen suchen doch die
belastung ist längst da und wird durch
die gas umlage ab herbst in jedem fall
noch größer landauf landab beschäftigt
dass politik privatleute unternehmen
auch heute hagen nicolas und luisa wogen
berichten aus sachsen anhalt
diese gießerei in quedlinburg verbraucht
jährlich so viel gas wie 250
einfamilienhäuser mit der gas umlage
steigen die gaskosten um mehr als die
hälfte ab oktober müsse die firma die
mehr kosten an ihre kunden weitergeben
die sorge die ich mir mache ist der
anruf der lautet auftrag storniert
auftrag storniert können wir nicht mehr
betreten zurück das problem und dann
kommt das nächste problem wann kommt
denn dann ein neuer auftragen derzeit
seien die auftragsbücher voll doch es
brauche mehr planungssicherheit
wie kriegen sie einen anruf vier stunden
bevor das gas weg ist oder für tage oder
vier wochen vorher wie wird das geregelt
und vor allem wann kommt es wieder und
ein ganz großer zweiter wichtiger punkt
fern ist wie wird denn eigentlich
das dann noch verfügbare restliche gas
verteilt um unabhängiger zu sein
investiert die gießerei in solar und
möchte zusätzlich flüssiggas nutzen
verflüssigtes erdgas aus übersee soll
auch eine lösung für ganz deutschland
sein dazu würden in wilhelmshaven und
brunsbüttel bis jahresende lng terminals
fertiggestellt so wirtschaftsminister
habeck am vormittag gleichzeitig das
signal dass deutschland über diese
infrastrukturen die fsa you schiffe in
brunsbüttel und philippsburg
wird kurz danach die ansage aus brüssel
auf die gasanlage müsse mehrwertsteuer
erhoben werden kritik daran gibt es auch
am rande eines energie gipfels in
magdeburg und die forderung diese
zusätzliche belastung zu kompensieren
notfalls auch in dem man generell mal
über eine ermäßigten steuersatz für
energieprodukte redet die notwendigkeit
bei der gas umlage nachzuarbeiten sieht
auch bundeskanzler scholz und können
dich dann nachmittag gespräche mit der
eu an sie wird mit uns über einen reden
wie wir das geld den bürgern wieder
zurückkommen lassen können und diesen
weg werden wir jetzt ganz schnell mit
der kommission besprechen dann ist ja
auch rechtssicher und kann umgesetzt
werden noch bevor die umlage erhoben
wird möglich wären sieben statt 19
prozent mehrwertsteuer auf energie das
würde verbraucher und unternehmen wie
die gießereien quedlinburg zumindest
etwas entlasten
weniger mehrwertsteuer das wünscht sich
die wirtschaft nicht nur in sachsen
anhalt das mit der ausnahme aus brüssel
für die gasanlage hat erst mal nicht
geklappt fragen wir nach bei alexander
pohl in brüssel alexander die eu
kommission ist sie nun einfach
halsstarrig oder geht am ende dann doch
noch was also mein eindruck war dass die
eu kommission vor allem verhindern will
dass es so einen flickenteppich aus
steuer regularien und steuersätzen in
europa geben soll daher zum teil heute
auch die ab die absage an die forderung
an christian lindner das bedeutet aber
nicht dass die bundesregierung jetzt
nichts tun kann um die menschen zu
entlasten
darauf hat powell jam filoni der
zuständige kommissar seinerseits auch in
einem brief auch hingewiesen er hat
gesagt es gibt natürlich ausnahmen im
eu-recht beispiel bei den energiesteuern
man könnte zum beispiel die
mehrwertsteuer auf erdgas auf fernwärme
oder auch auf strom auf 5 prozent senken
das geht jetzt schon also das ist nicht
das was christian lindner möchte man
möchte ja gar keine steuer erheben aber
man kann auch argumentieren dass diese
fünf prozent weniger sind als die 19
prozent die jetzt auf diese gas umlage
fällig werden insofern wäre das ein
möglicher notwendiger schritt aber ein
anderer schritt da müsste die
bundesregierung auch gar nicht groß um
erlaubnis bitten wäre natürlich in
deutschland die generelle senkung der
mehrwertsteuer auch das wird jetzt
gerade diskutiert ich denke dass es in
der debatte zwischen der eu kommission
und berlin auch darum gehen wird hier
bestimmte wege aufzuzeigen die es in der
gesetzgebung schon gibt die man aber in
berlin vielleicht noch nicht so sieht
danke alexander pohl für die erklärung
aus brüssel
niemand darf wegen seines geschlechts
seiner abstammung seiner rasse seiner
sprache seiner heimat und herkunft
seines glaubens seiner religiösen oder
politischen anschauungen benachteiligt
oder bevorzugt werden so steht es in
artikel 3 unseres grundgesetzes damit
dass auch eingehalten wird dafür
arbeitet unter anderem die
antidiskriminierungsstelle des bundes
erst 2006 eingerichtet und seitdem auch
seismograph für diskriminierung und
rassismus strömungen in der gesellschaft
die neue beauftragte ferda ataman
stellte heute die zahlen für 2021 vor
ihr erster auftritt in der neuen
funktion in die sie wirklich alles
andere als unumstritten gewählt wird wir
sprechen gleich mit ihr zunächst der
bericht von mathys weiter
es ist ein amt das kaum einer kennt oder
ein recht von dem kaum einer weiß
schneider ammann ist die neue
antidiskriminierungs beauftragte des
bundes bei ihr sammeln sich
diskriminierungserfahrungen nicht nur
wegen der hautfarbe oder der religion
der menschen ungerechtfertigt anders
behandelt verletzt also unsere
grundwerte und grundrechte
antidiskriminierung ist keineswegs nur
für minderheiten da es steht nicht nur
für den anspruch auf gleichheit es steht
auch für den anspruch auf freiheit das
grundgesetz liegt in artikel 3 die
grundlage für das amt alle menschen sind
vor dem gesetz gleich
es sind diskriminierungen die jeden tag
in der mitte der gesellschaft
stattfinden und die in beratungsstellen
wie hier in hamburg gemeldet und
behandelt werden mit tipps und
rechtlichem rat am arbeitsmarkt dass
menschen mit gleicher qualifikation
ständig stelle nicht bekommen und dann
langsam die idee bekommen es könnte an
meiner hautfarbe es könnte an meinem
kopf tores könnte an meinem namen liegen
ganz ähnlich ist es im wohnungsmarkt
beratungsstellen wie sie aber längst
nicht die regel sind und die deshalb
zahlen erfassen die nicht der
präsentation können der bericht nennt
für das jahr 20 21 rund 5600 einzelfälle
die meisten wegen rassismus oder
benachteiligung wegen einer behinderung
im verhältnis zu den vorjahren weiter
hoch aber es ist wohl nur die spitze
eines eisberges wir können bisher in
deutschland diskriminierung nicht in
zahlen fassen weil ist zu können studien
gibt wir können und müssen leider davon
ausgehen dass es millionen von fällen
gibt die berufung ackermanns als
beauftragte vorgeschlagen von den grünen
sollte das amt aufwerten doch sie wird
zur kontroverse als publizistin schrieb
sie von kartoffeln als beschreibung für
die deutschen oder von blut und boden
für den heimatbegriff von horst seehofer
provokation als stilmittel der
innenminister nahm 2018 deshalb nicht am
integrationsgipfels patermann ebenfalls
geladen bei ihrer wahl im bundestag gab
es nur eine knappe mehrheit von sieben
stimmen auch größere teile der koalition
stimmten gegen sie ein schwerer start
ich glaube dass beim thema anti
diskriminierung ist sehr sehr wichtig
ist dass man den finger in die wunde
legt dass man die probleme anspricht hat
man will jetzt vor allem das
antidiskriminierungsgesetz
reformieren ländergesetze anschieben und
diskriminierung durch den staat durch
behörden endlich einbeziehen
und jetzt ist sie uns live aus berlin
zugeschaltet schon am freitag mann
erschossen der kampf gegen
diskriminierung ist schon seit langem
ihr thema auch als journalistin als
kolumnistin als aktivistin was ist jetzt
anders im neuen amt
ich freue mich sehr dass ich die
möglichkeit habe für alle menschen eine
bundesbeauftragte zu sein und das ist ja
zum ersten mal so dass wir eine
bundesbeauftragten stelle haben dafür
für alle menschen die diskriminierung
erleben aufgrund des alters wegen einer
behinderung wegen verschiedenen gründen
die sie auch schon vorhin genannt haben
und das ist mir eine große ehre und eine
verpflichtung es jetzt haben sie ja in
der tat wieder mit gespart den leuten
auch ordentlich auf die füße zu treten
bewusst zu provozieren und damit bekommt
man in unserer gesellschaft heutzutage
ja im zweifel auch mehr aufmerksamkeit
wenn sie sich jetzt so auf die fahnen
schreiben ihr amt und auch das
antidiskriminierungsgesetz
bekannter zu machen können sie dann auf
das laute trommeln auf das anecken
eigentlich verzichten
mir geht es vor allem darum schelle
bekannt zu machen sie haben vorhin auch
schon einige genannt die fälle die wir
zum beispiel im jahresbericht haben
diese 5600 da geht es um menschen die
zum beispiel frauen die bei der
bewerbung beim bewerbungsgespräch
gefragt werden ob sie bald schwanger
werden wollen und dann deswegen nicht
eingestellt werden und solche fälle sind
für mich motivation und ich glaube die
fälle sprechen auch für sich
trotzdem muss man klartext weiterhin
benennen also probleme benennen den
finger in die wunde legen das will ich
auch weiterhin tun aber ich denke dass
man hier auf jeden fall sehr klar die
fakten für sich sprechen lassen kann
noch ist die kritik die er nicht nur
eine stilkritik ist an ihn nicht
verstummt heute wurde zum beispiel aus
der cdu erneut der vorwurf erhoben sie
blendeten im kampf gegen rassismus ein
teil des spektrums aus den rassismus und
antisemitismus unter migranten wie
wollen sie solche vorwürfe entkräften
die ja ihre arbeit dauerhaft belasten
können
also tatsächlich ist es so dass die
antidiskriminierungsstelle des bundes
fälle aus ganz ganz verschiedenen
bereichen hat ich hatte es ja auch von
schon genannt und wir bearbeiten die
alle und wir werden mit diesen fällen
arbeiten sozusagen und und jede form von
diskriminierung
sei sie antisemitisch sei sie
rassistisch aber eben auch betrifft die
menschen mit behinderungen sei es
frauenfeindlichkeit all das wird uns
beschäftigen wird mich beschäftigen und
ich kann die kritik dass sich jetzt hier
vielleicht auch einmal sagen so nicht
ganz nachvollziehen beziehungsweise kann
versichern dass es in meiner arbeit in
zukunft alles eine rolle spielen wird
weil es eben fälle sind die deutschland
betreffen keine blinden flecken sagen
sie wer muss da auch wen zu gehen gehen
sie auf ihre kritiker zu oder müssen die
zu ihnen kommen also es sind nach der
wahl auch schon viele auf mich
zugekommen
ich führe auch jetzt schon sehr sehr
viele bücher gespräche und genau das ist
ja auch die aufgabe einer solchen
bundesbeauftragten ich sehe es als meine
aufgabe eine breite allianz für
antidiskriminierung zu schaffen denn
dieses thema braucht eine breite allianz
es ist bisher vernachlässigt worden das
kombinieren an sich aber eben auch was
man tun kann für
antidiskriminierung und wir arbeiten
viel oder das möchte ich unbedingt auch
machen zum beispiel mit arbeitgeber
innen zusammen die ja ganz oft eben auf
der anderen seite sitzen also viele
diskriminierung finden märz platz statt
und da muss man eben beide seiten
mitnehmen völlig klar die die
rassistische diskriminierung nimmt mit
37 den größten teil der
beratungsanfragen einen sie haben heute
aber das fand ich interessant auch auf
eine andere form der diskriminierung
hingewiesen auf die wegen des sozialen
status das fällt nicht unter das gesetz
aber könnt ihr ja mit blick auf die lage
die wir derzeit hier haben hohe
energiekosten inflation verarmungsrisiko
auch an bedeutung noch zunehmen was
erwarten sie da mit blick auf den herbst
tatsächlich wird es sehr wahrscheinlich
eine große rolle spielen und es hat auch
eine gewisse soziale sprengkraft dass
menschen erleben dass sie eben wegen
ihres sozialen status oder weil sie
sozialhilfe empfänger innen sind nicht
genug in den blick genommen werden oder
bestimmte zugänge nicht haben und da
müssen wir auch oder da muss der
gesetzgeber auch nachjustieren im moment
ist diskriminierung aufgrund des
sozialen status nicht vom gesetz erfasst
vom diskriminierungsschutz sie haben es
gerade schon gesagt und das müssen wir
jetzt mit der anstehenden allgemeinen
gleichbehandlungsgesetz reform und ein
sehr langes wort angehen
sagt die neue beauftragte für
antidiskriminierung vater man herzlichen
dank danke ihm für
die zweite wochenhälfte kündigt sich
regen an was in diesem sommer eine
wirklich gute nachricht ist obwohl
gewitter und starkregen der von den
trockenen böden kaum aufgenommen werden
kann dürften die lage nicht nachhaltig
entspannen dafür ist sie zu ernst der
rhein meldet auch heute niedrigwasser
durch die eingeschränkte
binnenschifffahrt drohen
versorgungsengpässe für unternehmen und
die energieversorgung
besorgniserregend ist die lage auch
weiter im osten an der spree wegen des
extremen niedrigwassers lässt
brandenburg schleusen im spreewald
schließen damit der hauptfluss der spree
nicht versiegt er dann richtung berlin
fließt aus brandenburg berichtet jan
meyer arnulf weingart ist dort wo
touristen selten hinkommen mitten im
unteren spreewald bekommt der gänse
fliesst seit ein paar tagen kein wasser
mehr
und dass wer ist geschlossen ein teil
des biosphärenreservats ist
trockengelegt der naturschützer ist
empört auch
im sommer wenn genügend wasser da es und
hier wird wasser eingeleitet steht das
ungefähr bis zum
dritten ehe von oben gesehen dann ist
das ein schönes fließgewässer hier sind
fische drin hier kann der schwarz
durchdringe fischen in dem gebiet wir
wird nämlich im ältesten
naturschutzgebiete spreewald ist im
krieg busch gestern wurde auch dieses
wer bereits geschlossen damit ist jetzt
zufluss in die dame ein nebenfluss
gesperrt das wasser fließt hier komplett
nur noch in die spree nach berlin weiter
die touristen im oberen spreewald
bekommen den mangel zu spüren durch die
niedrigen wasserstände sind nicht mehr
alle fließe befahrbar
wenn man sieht dass da der wasserpegel
niedriger ist als man sieht an die
markierung der räume
die oder ist fast auf ihren historischen
tiefstand gesunken kaum zu glauben vor
genau 25 jahren kämpften die menschen
hier gegen die jahrhundertflut die die
innenstadt von frankfurt oder zu
überschwemmen drohte dirk triebler hat
es immer schwerer mit seinen bootstouren
über den fluss in dem vorige woche
tonnenweise fische verendeten für große
gruppen reicht die wassertiefe gar nicht
mehr aus
wir haben drei schiffe die für
unterschiedliche gruppengrößen notwendig
sind und mit dem größten von dem können
wir momentan auch nicht mehr fahren und
mit den beiden kleineren schiffen geht
es noch die schwarze elster in
südbrandenburg führt seit wochen kein
wasser mehr nicht zum ersten mal seit
2008 zehn leidet brandenburg unter dürre
sommern und die aussichten sind schlecht
für die rund 30.000 kilometer flüsse und
bäche die ihr klimamodell ihre gehen
davon aus dass wir trotz
gleichbleibenden regen aber durch die
steigenden temperaturen weniger wasser
zur verfügung haben werden weniger
wasser in der landschaft haben werden so
dass wir davon mich persönlich auch
davon ausgehe dass wir
sehen verlieren werden dass wir
fließgewässer verlieren werden also die
trocken fallen werden im spreewald
bleiben sogar schleusen geschlossen
kanufahrer müssen ihre boote selber
tragen so soll das wasser langsam
abfließen touristen helfen mit die
kulturlandschaft vor dem austrocknen zu
retten
im ukraine krieg hat es erneut heftige
explosionen in einem munitionsdepot auf
der abt von russland annektierten
halbinsel krim gegeben damit beginnen
die nachrichten jetzt von gundula gause
ja das russische
verteidigungsministerium spricht von
einem sabotageakt bei dem auch zivile
infrastruktur zerstört worden sei nur
wenige menschen sollen verletzt worden
sein 3000 allerdings mussten in
sicherheit gebracht werden aus kiel hieß
es es handele sich um eine meisterlich
ausgeführte operation zur
entmilitarisierung der krim auch am
atomkraftwerk sapori cia dauern die
kämpfe an residenz elends geforderte
russland erneut auf sich von dem akw
zurückzuziehen und warnte vor einer
nuklearen katastrophe
deutschland und schweden haben der
ukraine weitere militärische
unterstützung zugesagt in bezug auf den
nato-beitritt schweden sagte
bundeskanzler scholz er sei
zuversichtlich dass es jetzt sehr
schnell gehen werde mit der ebenfalls
sozialdemokratischen ministerpräsidentin
andersen vereinbarte er auch gemeinsamer
anstrengungen beim ausbau der
erneuerbaren energien schweden werde
allerdings so andersen noch lange zeit
an der atomkraft festhalten
die generalstaatsanwaltschaft hamburg
sieht in der sogenannten comics affäre
kein fehlverhalten von olaf scholz und
wird nicht gegen den bundeskanzler
ermitteln die beschwerde eines anwalts
dagegen dass sie nicht ermittelt wurde
zurückgewiesen in seiner amtszeit als
erster bürgermeister der hansestadt
2016 hatten die finanzbehörden darauf
verzichtet 47 millionen euro aus comics
geschäften der hamburger warburg-bank
zurückzufordern
im prozess um die amokfahrt von trier
bei der im dezember 2020 fünf menschen
getötet worden waren ist der angeklagte
zu einer lebenslangen freiheitsstrafe
wegen mehrfachen mordes verurteilt
worden das gericht sah es als erwiesen
an dass der 52 jährige mit einem auto in
die fußgängerzone gerast war um
möglichst viele menschen zu töten oder
zu verletzen
aufgrund der besonderen schwere der
schuld wird der täter seine strafe in
einer geschlossenen psychiatrie verbüßen
auch eine woche nach entdeckung der
umweltkatastrophe in der oder ist die
ursache des fischsterbens noch immer
nicht geklärt allein die polnische
feuerwehr hat bislang fast 100 tonnen
toter fische aus dem grenzfluss geworden
erste laborergebnisse weisen lediglich
auf erhöhte salz und sauerstoffwerte hin
betroffen sind auch mehrere mit der oder
verbundene kanäle in der folge könnten
verseuchte wassermassen die ostsee
erreichen die eu-kommission hat
unterstützung bei der aufklärung
angeboten
chinas staatschef hat einen großen traum
und einen plan dazu er will ein mächtig
werden china politisch und
wirtschaftlich als führende weltmacht zu
positionieren dafür hat er sein land in
den letzten zehn jahren zunehmend
autokratisch regiert menschen und
freiheitsrechte eingeschränkt hongkong
unterworfen der gürtel um taiwan wird
enger beim zwanzigster parteitag der
kommunistischen partei im herbst will
sich hier in ping nun für die dritte
amtszeit bestätigen lassen und
untermauert seine macht derzeit vor
allem auf dem land in der provinz yunnan
seien durch seinen persönlichen einsatz
millionen menschen aus der armut geführt
worden
erfolgsgeschichten die sich hier etwa im
dorf schieber dong am besten erzählen
und inszenieren lassen wir unsere
korrespondentin miriam stein erlebt hat
das ist nicht irgendeine sitzgruppe sie
ist hier so wichtig dass sie im museum
steht denn hier sagt der chinesische
präsident bei seinem besuch 2013 auch
das dorf das hing damals besichtigt hat
fühlt sich an wie ein museum ein museum
in dem die fotos von der wand lebendig
werden
ich war 64 als der generalsekretär kam
und mein leben ist heute viel besser
nach seinem besuch hat sich die
tourismusindustrie hier sehr schnell
entwickelt und ich danke der partei und
dem generalsekretär dafür
heute ist super dran 73 und teil des
museums im superdome im süden chinas
bei seinem besuch versprach die menschen
auf dem land von armut zu befreien dass
er sein versprechen eingelöst hat das
sollen wir sehen denn wir sind auf einer
pressereise organisiert vom chinesischen
staat und der hat auch das thema
ausgewählt das geht nicht ertragen
aktuelle krisen wie corona oder die
schwächelnde wirtschaft sondern um
armutsbekämpfung auf dem land und nichts
passiert hier zufällig auch lehrer dong
ist auf unserem besuch gut vorbereitet
generalsekretär sie ist den menschen
nahe liebt sie und kümmert sich sehr um
und
totale kontrolle über die bilder über
die berichterstattung das ist das ziel
des staats wir sollen zeigen wie sehr
sich das leben hier verbessert hat alle
menschen aus extremer armut befreit das
ist eine sehr gute grundlage und ein
gutes klima für einen erfolgreichen
zwanzigster parteitag auf diesem
parteitag im herbst will sich hier eine
dritte amtszeit sichern für seine
vorgänger bisher nicht möglich dazu
braucht er die massen auf dem land denn
in den großstädten wächst der unmut über
seine corona politik die immer noch
strengen maßnahmen schaden der
wirtschaft und gefährden sein
versprechen das volk reich zu machen
umso wichtiger zu zeigen wie sehr sich
das leben auf dem land verbessert hat
früher konnten die bauern ihre produkte
nicht transportieren um sie zu verkaufen
jetzt kommen viele touristen die
sojabohnen und wassermelonen hier kaufen
die infrastruktur ist heute besser die
idee brücke ist eines der
erfolgsprojekte die uns präsentiert
werden und dass sie bereits eröffnet war
bevor ich präsident wurde wird nicht
erwähnt er hat milliarden in die
armutsbekämpfung gesteckt und das leben
vieler verbessert wie wichtig ist es
dass zu zeigen zeigt aber auch wie sehr
er unter druck steht
normalerweise wenn bei unseren
dreharbeiten in china die polizei
auftaucht bedeutet dass lange diskussion
heute winken die beamten zum abschied
freundlich
in den nachrichten kommen wir noch
einmal zurück auf das thema gas umlage
gundela die nun definierte höhe der gas
umlage ab oktober mit all ihren folgen
beschäftigt auch die finanzmärkte
mehrere energieversorger positionieren
sich beantragen zahlungen oder erklären
auf erstattungen zu verzichten sina
mainitz an der börse wie werden denn die
unterschiedlichen positionierungen bei
den kunden ankommen ja das kommt ganz
darauf an gundula bei welchem
energieversorger sich der kunde denn
tatsächlich befindet und woher dieser
wiederum sein gas bezieht einige sind
stark abhängig von russischem gas und
die seit längerem reduzierte gasmenge
aus russland muss kompensiert werden und
dann zum teuren tagesaktuellen preis
eingekauft werden um diesen dann
auszugleichen sollen die firmen mit
hilfe der gasanlage finanziell
unterstützt werden die höheren preise
werden nun teilweise an die kunden
weitergegeben so haben bisher den antrag
auf die gasanlage die enbw tochter vng
der oldenburger energieversorger ewe und
juniper gestellt morgen früh wird es
dann spannend dann nämlich
veröffentlichte finanziell gebeutelte
konzern juniper seine halbjahreszahlen
alles andere als finanziell gebeutelt
sind diese energieversorger rwe
produziert seinen strom selbst und kann
diesen in krisenzeiten sogar zu deutlich
höheren preisen verkaufen auch shell hat
im ersten halbjahr des jahres
rekordgewinne eingefahren
beide branchenriesen verzichten deshalb
offenbar auf die gasanlage das ganze
könnte aber auch noch einen anderen
hintergrund haben nämlich einerseits das
image aufpolieren und andererseits
könnten sie so die debatte um diese über
gewinn steuer umschiffen mit ihr sollen
ja unternehmen die von krieg und
energiepreise krise besonders profitiert
haben höher besteuert werden ob sie aber
tatsächlich kommt bleibt offen es zeigt
aber eines die energiebranche spaltet
sich rund um das thema gas in zwei lager
vielen dank für die einordnung sina nach
frankfurt
zwei meldungen vom sport der zehnkämpfer
niclas kohl hat in einer sensationellen
aufholjagd bei der heim wm in münchen
gold geholt der 24 jährige mainzer
konnte mit einem starken speerwurf
punkte gutmachen er ging als favorit in
den 1500 meter lauf und siegte mit
großem abstand silber geht an den
schweizer simon hammer bronze an de
nächsten jahr plane karl ist der sechste
deutsche athlet der zehnkampf
europameister wird mit
und bei den bahnrad
europameisterschaften in münchen haben
sich auch die deutschen sprinter den
abschluss vergoldet oder kluge und theo
reinhardt aus berlin fuhren überlegen
auf den ersten platz in madison zuvor
konnte lea sophie friederich jubeln auch
sie holte gold im keirin wettbewerb und
maximilian dörnbach gewann silber im
1000 meter zeitfahren
insgesamt fuhren die deutschen
bahnradfahrer 13 medaillen ein davon
achtmal gold und
dann vor einer guten stunde diese
nachricht der star regisseur wolfgang
petersen ist tot mit 81 jahren erlag er
einer krebserkrankung geboren in emden
führte sein weg ihn nach hollywood wo
der deutsche eine geradezu fantastische
karriere machte abteilung blockbuster
das boot das war petersen und viel viel
mehr bernd gummelt erinnert er war der
mann für großes kino hollywood
leinwandstars standen schlange in der
deutsche regisseur wolfgang petersen
rief
von ganz unten in den film olymp schafft
er ist der sohn eines marineoffiziers
aus enden
hier habe ich in baracken gelebt im
hafen in einer unglaublichen armut
in den späten vierziger jahren meine
eltern wussten gar nicht wie sie
eigentlich uns ernähren sollten mit der
verbindung von buchheims bestseller das
boot landete petersen einen welterfolg
[Musik]
das boot hat mein ganzes leben verändert
das ist ganz klar ich hatte viel viel
fernsehen ja vorher gemacht und dann kam
plötzlich dieser gigantische große
kinofilm auch die deutsch-amerikanische
fantasy verfilmung von michael endes die
unendliche geschichte beflügelte seine
karriere gedreht in einer riesigen
wassertank der sturm george clooney noch
aufwendiger sein untergang der poseidon
trotz starbesetzung ausnahmsweise mal
kein kassenhit für den erfolgsverwöhnten
erfolg ist ein hollywood natürlich alles
wenn man jetzt einen guten trainer der
nicht läuft und keiner guckt in hand da
wäre ich schon längst wieder hier und
da habe ich für die firmengeschichte
machte petersen auch sein antiken mythos
troja
mit 75 feierte peterson sein comeback in
der alten heimat dreht in berlin das
remake seines deutschen tv krimis von
1976 nun verabschiedete sich
deutschlands erfolgreichste regisseur in
hollywood für immer von dieser welt
wolfgang peters wir weisen sie jetzt
gerne auf unsere reportage 37 grad hin
es geht um kinder die sich um ihre
erkrankten eltern kümmern und über sich
hinauswachsen müssen große last auf
schmalen schultern sehr sehenswert und
um mitternacht gibt es dann wieder unser
heute-journal update so ist es mit
gundula gause übrigens zusammen sind wir
morgen wieder für sie da
[Musik]
guten abend der wind hat gedreht die
strömungen kommt jetzt aus südwest und
damit kommt gewitter luft zu uns und
dafür verantwortlich ist dass tief karin
das morgen bereits südfrankreich
erreicht haben wird heute nacht sinken
die temperaturen an der ostsee auf 19
grad bis auf 11 grad geht es runter zum
beispiel am alpenrand im osten ist es
heute nacht klar im westen gibt es mehr
wolken und zum frühen morgen beginnt es
bereits mit den ersten regenschauern und
die weiten sich dann morgen vormittag
über die westlichen mittelgebirge aus
zwischen der ostseeküste und der donau
dagegen ist es noch sehr sonnig am
nachmittag verdichten sich dann die
wolken im westen es gibt kräftige
schauer und gewitter und am abend liegen
die gewitter schwerpunkte zum einen im
westlichen niedersachsen zum anderen in
baden württemberg unter den dichteren
wolken im westen gegen morgen die
höchsttemperaturen nur bei 26 29 grad
richtung osten ist es noch mal heiß mit
höchstwerten von 30 bis 34 grad das ist
aber der letzte sehr heiße tag in
deutschland denn bis samstag ist die
hitze aus deutschland weg geräumt dann
haben wir nur noch höchsttemperaturen
zwischen 18 grad an den alpen und 25
grad im rhein-main-gebiet
jetzt kommen die kräftigen gewittern und
zwar in der nacht zu donnerstag und
donnerstag über tag das sind unwetter
die mit hagel platzregen und sturmböen
verbunden sind und die am freitag
bereits den osten deutschlands erreicht
haben am samstag beruhigt sich die lage
eben bei nur noch 18 bis 25 grad guten
abend